[Music]
it's easy to look at Donald Trump and
think oh god this guy's nuts
or oh god he's gonna make America white
again but here's a radical thought maybe
all of that all the focus on what a
president Trump could do is a bit of a
distraction maybe a big distraction if
we're afraid that a trump presidency
means that rights and freedoms enjoyed
by Americans will be disrupted and that
hate will reign well we don't really
have to wait for Trump for that to
happen
take for example how in December 2015
the US Senate voted in favor of
defunding Planned Parenthood just a week
after Robert Lewis dear shot up a
Colorado Springs clinic leaving three
people dead and nine injured now
President Obama has said that he'll veto
the bill which is great but the issue is
about so much more than funding the
opposition to a woman's health
organization is that it provides amongst
other things
safe and accessible abortions and as a
reminder abortion is legal in the United
States women have been granted the right
to choose for themselves what's best for
their reproductive health and while we
may not consider the issue of Planned
Parenthood as something that affects all
American women it does often affect the
lives and decisions of some of the
country's most vulnerable and
underprivileged women and speaking of
underprivileged there are all the
deportations Trump early in his campaign
made what people thought was the wild
suggestion of deporting 11 million
undocumented immigrants but under
President Obama there have already been
over 2 million of them more than any
number deported under any other
President now yes President Obama in
November 2014 issued an executive order
which would prevent millions of
undocumented immigrants in the country
from being deported but with hundreds of
thousands of unaccompanied children and
families fleeing violence from Central
America making the potential refugees
home raids overflowing detention centers
and mass deportations aren't solving any
crisis and we really can't forget that
thing called racism that affects
millions of Americans on a day-to-day
basis whether the disproportionate
imprisonment of black and Latino men or
the continued racial segregation of
schools across the country
system isn't just a slur but a lived
reality after all this is a country
where twelve-year-old carrying a replica
gun in an open carry state can be gunned
down by police within two seconds of
arriving on the scene and walk away
without legal consequence this is a
country where the twelve-year-old gets
blamed wear a hoodie gets blamed
it's where an unarmed 18 year old is
gunned down by a cop and is called no
angel and a white mass shooter is
described as quiet and soft-spoken and
it's a country where Supreme Court
justice can call the Voting Rights Act
of 1965 a racial entitlement and suggest
that black students are better off in
less advanced slower track schools
because classes in competitive schools
might be too fast for them and if you're
worried about Muslim Americans under a
trump presidency well they've been used
to mass surveillance deportation
entrapment and collective suspicion
amongst other things for over 15 years
the hypotheticals that a trump
presidency could bring are definitely
worrying and so are the realities that
millions in this country have been
living with for decades
[Music]